la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
ignorions nous la nature fait l'identité
de ceux qui ont commis des actes
terroristes cette année si en france
avant ça en espagne en italie en
belgique au royaume-uni etc
la réponse est non ce type est inconnue
donc on ne vient pas me dire qu'il
fallait qu'on puisse les repérer ils
étaient repérés ils étaient repérés donc
le pnr en l'occurrence n'aurait servi à
rien du tout ces types sont venus en
voiture en métro mais pas du tout par
l'avion alors bien sûr il suit remplir
l'avion depuis 126 lits et bien on les a
repérés donc on n'a pas eu besoin d'un
pnr européen pour les repérer c'est ce
que je constate
et donc on voudrait nous faire croire
que lens qui vous fait peur dans le pnr
et c'est pas une question de faire peur
c'est une question de principe
veuillez trouvez vous normal que toutes
les données de tous les passagers de
tous les vols qui circulent en europe
soient collectées sans aucun mandat
judiciaire est fourni en vrac aux
services de police
c'est là quelque chose qui en fait est
complètement disproportionnée par
rapport à l'objectif recherché